salut s'érode et ben en fait avant on
habitait à saint malo dans 1,45 mètre
carré et maintenant on habite à saint
georges de reintembault dans un 1800
mètres carrés donc venez venez donc bah
on a commencé la destruction des murs au
lendemain de noël
je savais pas quoi faire au lendemain de
noël je me suis battu je commence à
faire des travaux
donc ici petit séjour petit séjour de 57
mètres carrés petit par rapport au
bâtiment est ici c'est dans l'ancienne
salle de chimie physique et donc les
trois premiers quarts où ça sera la
cuisine dînatoire et deux autres carreau
ce sera toi les deux salles de bain en
fait ce 1800 la carre que vous voyez en
fait c'était un ancien collège qui
s'appelait le bocage qui a eu une
activité très courte de 1974 à 1994
s'il ya bien un truc que le confinement
nous a appris c'est que tout était
possible
je pense que si tu ne changes pas de vis
maintenant tu changeras jamais ont
cherché partout en france bien
immobilier quelle que soit sa nature à
moins de 50000 euros est inférieur ou
égal à 50 millions
pendant ce temps là
[Musique]
c'est le projet d'une vie de deux vies
pour coup mais pourquoi pas mais
pourquoi pas voilà comment en quelques
clics juste après le premier confinement
road et aurélie ont complètement changé
de vie en devenant propriétaire de cet
ancien lycée agricole le projet
d'origine et il est vraiment apparu
quand on est tombé sur cette page sur le
bon coin on se dit non mais c'est juste
fou on pourrait vraiment faire ça même
dans les rêves les plus fous n'aurais
jamais pu imaginer ça et ça ils l'ont
surnommé le collège fou fou fou
il faudrait inventer un collège fou fou
fou où tout le monde est fou et rien que
pour nous et c'est vraiment ça en fait
c'est sûr que c'est peut-être pas normal
de se lancer dans un truc comme ça
mais est-ce que c'est grave d'être
normal ou anormal veut dire l'important
c'est d'être heureux en fait est là pour
l'instant on n'a jamais été aussi
heureux c'est ici qu'ils vont vivre
d'ici la fin de l'année
enfin ça c'est ce qu'ils espèrent alors
ici on est dans la partie culturelle la
partie maison si tu ne changes pas de
plan tu vas voir on y est bientôt
[Musique]
là on est à la maison ronde et aurélie
soit transformé la majorité du lieu en
un vaste espace culturel avec salles de
concerts d'expositions et un étage
entièrement dédié au street art
le deuxième étape et tout ça dans un
village de moins de 1500 habitants
alors peut-être que pour beaucoup de
gens la culture ce n'est pas primordial
sauf que maintenant qu'on a ça fait un
an qu'on a plus de cinéma plus de
théâtre fut de concert plus de musées je
pense que beaucoup de gens peut-être
maintenant réalise qu'il n'y a pas plus
important au niveau sociabilisation
d'une vie que la culture c'est comme là
où on rencontre nos amis nos futurs
amour pour ces rencontres et sur un
concert ça prendra le temps qu'il faudra
et petit à petit on va construire notre
note chez zoé et l terra et puis on va
on va y aller petit à petit pas à pas de
pression zéro pression avant cette étape
là c'était il y avait une partie
internat et salles de classe et est en
fait dans le futur ça va être une partie
dédiée au street art ça c'est notre cour
petit cours de et me semble que sur le
cadastre elle doit faire 3200 mètres
carrés après ça peut être fou si on
devait rénover tout le collège est là où
il a rénové la totalité du bâtiment
c'est ça le le bâtiment est tellement
très bon état qu'on peut laisser une
bonne partie tel quel mais en limitant
bien sûr les accès de pluie neige ou est
ce que c'est ça qui détruit énormément
un bâtiment quand on le laisse dans un
état sauvage en voix chaude partie
maison vu que aller entre guillemets
petit par rapport à la surface du
bâtiment parce que je te rappelle que
ces cinq carreaux qui sont là parmi tous
les autres carreau mais là le plus
difficile pour nous pour donner une
deadline très précis c'est qu'on n'a
toujours pas trouvé pour l'instant de
plombier donc on profite pour passer une
annonce auprès de brut située plombier
dans le 35 le côté saint georges de
reintembault on est chauds pourtant
bauchet vraiment parce que là c'est
compliqué ça sera la chute
ouais c'est vrai
[Rires]